so um i hate to break it to many of the
people in the audience who think that
just more guns in more places will make
everybody safer
but there was at least one armed officer
at the school in uvalde texas yesterday
where this horrible mass shooting took
place there was at least one armed
officer there who was unable to stop the
incident okay so what republicans are
now going to is no no this isn't about
guns or gun safety or whatever we need
more guns in school so that the teachers
and the administrators and the janitors
and the whoever can protect the kids
let's go to some examples from yesterday
this is the immediate aftermath of the
shooting in uvalde texas asked on
newsmax how he would deal with the
school shooting problem in texas the
texas attorney general ken paxton said
well let's arm the teachers as as you
well know the state of texas not a
stranger to shootings that either begin
in schools or wander into schools
i know your team has dealt with this
before what were some of the solutions
and i know that governor abbott and
lieutenant governor patrick have also
come up with tasks for task forces to
harden these task forces and oh yeah
yeah guys what about the guns schools so
they're not easy targets easy prey for
crazy people who go nuts with firearms
uh
what what can you tell us has been
remember crazy people who go nuts with
firearms well i'd rather have crazy
people who go nuts with a knife than
with assault rifles that's just me
talked about in the past what has been
implemented and what hasn't been
yeah sadly this has happened again and
it's a horrible tragedy but the types of
things that we talked about and i'll
never forget it after the santa fe
shooting it was having one point of
entry making it more difficult for
people even to get in that point of
entry make sure that they
and having potentially teachers and
other administrators who have gone
through training who are armed because
teachers and administrators who have
gone through training and who are armed
they're all on this bandwagon texas
lieutenant governor dan patrick went on
tucker carlson's show last night and
said let's harden the targets we can do
a lot of things and texas has done a lot
of things after the santa fe shooting uh
obviously we have to do more we have to
harden these targets so no one can get
in ever except through one entrance
maybe that would would help maybe that
would stop someone but it's really
bigger than that tucker it's we're a
core society we're we're a society
that's just at each other's throats all
the time and and and we're better than
we're better than this as a nation we
have to harden targets schools now
they have to be hardened and at least
dan patrick is getting at the fact that
there is a cultural component here
although he would say it's just
political disagreement if the liberals
would just let us ban abortion and put
guns everywhere and make taxes on the
rich zero you know at least if well the
actually part of the problem is the gun
culture of the united states uh radical
republican texas senator ted cruz said
oh yeah you've got to just arm the
teachers and uh rather you've got you've
got to have more armed cops there we
know from past experience that the most
effective tool for keeping kids safe
uh is armed law enforcement on the
campus you know inevitably when there's
a murder of this kind
you see politicians trying to try to
politicize it you see democrats and a
lot of folks in the media whose
immediate solution is to try to
restrict
the constitutional rights of law-abiding
citizens that doesn't work yeah
um and then lastly a newsmax host named
um i believe this is grant stinkfield
he says uh you've got to have armed good
guys at the schools that's the only way
well folks by now you have heard about
this animal that went into rob
elementary school this morning in the
tiny call it a border town called uvalde
texas
this animal murdered 18 elementary
school kids and three adults now numbers
keep rising my heart aches for the loved
ones of all of the victims as i watch
the media today play out its
wall-to-wall coverage of the shooting
they only seem to talk about guns
deranged violent individuals and how we
keep guns out of their hands if you want
to save lives you can talk about that
it's important but the number one issue
that needs to be discussed is how do you
stop a gunman the moment he comes
calling
the answer is secure our schools it's
still not happening and in my opinion
institute programs where school faculty
can carry in school after going through
in-depth training on a voluntary basis
yeah so listen um there are reports that
two uvaldi police officers and a school
resource officer
fired at the shooter but weren't able to
stop him from entering the building
that's one report
we're still working on confirming that
but at minimum according to eric estrada
from the texas department of public
safety
there was at least the school district
police officer who worked at the school
and saw the shooter
with a rifle
with body armor engaged the suspect and
was unable to stop him so quite
literally there were supposed good guys
with guns there and they still didn't
stop him now their reaction instead of
saying well maybe the problem is how
easily the the kid got guns
they say we just didn't have enough good
guys with guns at the school you
essentially need an army there they will
not stop until
it is
they would rather turn schools almost
into like forward operating bases
reminiscent of the military rather than
restrict access to guns and um by the
way
the people now they're saying let's give
the guns to the teachers
these are the same teachers that for the
last two years they've been saying these
are the indoctrinators these are the
critical race theory teaching
irresponsible indoctrinators who are
grooming our kids
those are the people that now they want
to give the guns to it's whatever will
justify keeping as many guns as possible
around that's the bottom line the rest
of the world looks at us like we're
insane
and at some point you have to wonder are
we insane
um
when you look at correlation isn't
necessarily causation
but look at this correlation between
guns and mass shootings from the new
york times the u.s has the most guns and
the most shootings no one else is even
close in guns no one else is even close
in shootings now i concede
we have a problem here with gun culture
but the same people that want to keep
the guns around like that culture so
they're not going to solve that
there is sometimes a mental illness
component but the people saying that's
the problem don't want to fund treatment
for mental health but might it not be
worth seeing what happens if we limit
the number of guns that are out there
and i hate to be so negative and cynical
but if nothing was done after 26 kids
were killed in sandy hook in 2012
is something ever going to be done about
this i don't know
i don't know
um
let me know your thoughts
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well chili sleeps product the
uhler the cube and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get 30 off of the uhler
and cube sleep systems and 10 percent
off the new doc pro this offer is only
for my audience the link is down below